as of July of 2013 one and a half
million new Android devices were being
activated every day so it's hard to
believe that just a few years ago I
started all meetings with potential
developers explaining what Android was
and convincing them it was worth their
time and effort developing for the
platform
it wasn't until 2010 that we even shared
numbers to indicate the growth of the
platform a hundred thousand daily
activations in May of that year which
quickly grew to 500,000 in mid-2011 and
crossed the million daily activations
mark in 2012 that represents over a
billion Android devices around the world
which is why I don't start my
presentations asking if anyone in the
room has an Android device anymore to me
though the biggest surprise in those
early days was how much effort was
required to convince people that
developing for mobile at all was a
worthwhile investment a huge number of
people use their phones to go online and
many of them use their phone as the main
way to do so one study by the Pew
Research internet project in 2013 that
nearly two-thirds of mobile owners use
their phones to go online double the
rate found in 2009 and then a third of
phone users use mostly their phone to
get online think about that for a second
these portable phones have become pocket
computers constantly connected to the
cloud to make the sum of human knowledge
available to us at a touch at a glance
it's no wonder then that for a growing
number of people mobile isn't how to get
online when you're away from your desk
it's actually displacing pcs as their
primary computing platform the change is
so dramatic in the trends so clear that
companies like Google who depend
entirely on the Internet
have a mobile first policy ensuring that
the mobile experience is the first
consideration when building new products
this trend is particularly evident
amongst younger users who grew up using
mobiles and especially in emerging
markets like Africa and Asia where the
infrastructure does support ubiquitous
broadband for desktops isn't as readily
available I saw this firsthand when I
had the good fortune to visit Kenya a
few years ago ubiquitous phones and
passionate talented developers were
really familiar but what really struck
me was the degree to which mobile phones
had
an integral part of people's everyday
lives he wasn't just checking email and
posting to Facebook it was using him
pasta to buy everything from groceries
to bus fare
mobiles were such a part of life that I
heard rather than buying someone a drink
to show that you're interested you'd
send them a phone credit so that they
could call you if they felt the same way
and the transition of smartphones from
tech accessory to a part of life to the
main way you get online to how you pay
for things even how you flirt represents
a huge opportunity for us as developers
the question is how are you going to
change the world